hello everyone we are please have a
heavy join us for cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast colon cancer diagnostic tool
fecal occult blood testing in the modern
Europe I am Bob Woodard and all be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by he masseur Hema sure is a
worldwide recognized you know logical
fecal occult blood cast Fran known for
quality accuracy and reliability Hema
sure is dedicated to saving lives
educating patients on the importance of
getting screened for colorectal cancer
for more information visit key masseur
calm we have a few important
announcements to make before we begin
this presentation has been approved for
continuing education credits please
click on the CD button on the bottom
left corner of the auditorium this will
direct you to the necessary site and
form needed for your credits this
webcast is designed to be interactive we
encourage you to ask questions during
the presentation to submit your
questions you can type them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon on the right hand lower
right hand corner of this screen window
if you have any technical problems you
are hearing this presentation please
click on the support button in the upper
right hand corner of the presentation
window or submit your questions in the
Q&A box on the lower left following this
presentation head over to the community
of learning in the lab exchange lobby to
have the opportunity to engage in live
chat and have more of your questions
answered on this on the spot about
pulling cancer diagnostic tool people
occult blood casting in the modern era I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker Rob kiss for loose
rob is the southeast manager for him
ashore he's a specialty expert in rapid
diagnostic medical devices with
enthusiasm colorectal cancer awareness
this belief is that we're all part of a
team and the goals of the team are
simple save lives and or improve the
quality of what the tasks for each of us
may differ but the goal should remain
the same Rob's favorite task is
educating health care providers on new
recommendations and methodologies he
loves to see the aha moment when they
not only understand how to perform a
test but more importantly why Rob will
continue to learn educate and
disseminate beneficial information
through the masses please join me in
welcoming Rob to today's event I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you Bob I appreciate that welcome
everyone I appreciate the time you're
going to spend with me today we're going
to do some learning on a topic that's
very near and dear to my heart or should
I say near and dear to my but before we
get rolling as I talk through to my
introduction you're going to see some
poll questions so please answer those
poll questions everyone so that I have
an idea of who you are so that we can
make this lecture tailored a little bit
more to the audience again welcome I am
Rob Kissel Lucy and we're going to speak
in generic terms not necessarily having
anything to do with my role here at Hema
sure so you will be able to walk away
with this hopefully after the hour that
we spent together with a better
understanding of what new
recommendations are and how to have
better patient care as well as a revenue
stream for a lot of your facilities with
the newer style of fecal occult blood
testing I understand that a lot of you
are fully aware that the fecal occult
blood test is used in many different
areas not just colorectal cancer
screening we are going to focus on the
colorectal cancer screening aspect of
the fecal occult blood test today so as
we move through everything we will
answer questions at the end and
hopefully if you have more in-depth
questions that would like to discuss
different things we can join each other
in the community of learning after the
conclusion of the lecture so once again
thank you for your time and again we're
going to talk about the quiet
methodology of colorectal cancer
screening versus the newer technology
and technologies we're going to go over
a few of them we're going to focus on
what was recommended by the american
college of gastroenterology when they
made their latest round of updates at
the end of 2008 we're going to talk
about specifics between different
methodologies we're going to talk
so why certain methodologies are
recommended over others if you see me
out about I do my share of traveling to
different trade shows and different
meetings you can say hey Rob saw your
lecture loved it hated it give me
feedback there is as much as you'd like
to do so you can commonly refer to me as
the poop guy that's what I'm known out
there in the field is so if you forget
that my name is Rob just say hey poop
guy come on over here I've got a
question for you and we will have a
discussion for whatever you want to do
I'm going to give you a couple seconds
to finish off these poll questions but
in my introduction Bob spoke something
that's very passionate to me all of us
in healthcare get focused on our daily
tasks we have a lot of work on our plate
because if everyone is like I am you're
doing the job of three different people
and now and you're expected to do all on
your own so we get focused on our daily
tasks in in this healthcare business
that we're in and we have a lot to do
that a lot of times we lose sight of the
fact that we all have a common goal that
common goal is either to stabilize or to
make the quality of life better for
people when you take a step back and you
think of it in terms of that frame of
reference it really gives us a little
bit of a breath of fresh air or a
breather from our daily test to really
focus on what's important and why we do
what we do so whether you are a supplier
whether you are a vendor whether you are
working in a healthcare facility in a
capacity of being a nurse and na a
physician somebody in procurement
someone that works the front desk
somebody that's in billing we're all in
this together we all have the same
common goal let's uh let's try to work
together to help everyone out think of
it in terms of your own family members
what kind of treatment would you like
for your mother your father your son
your daughter your brother your sister
when you going to get your health care
needs taken care of if we really focus
on those types of things we try to make
it an easier environment for everyone to
achieve the same goals that we have
we're almost finished with the poll
questions and we'll go ahead and wrap
those up in a second and I will begin
with the actual lecture at hand thank
you for allowing me the extra couple
minutes to give my viewpoint on how
we're all together in this endeavor that
we call healthcare appreciate that I'm
going to go ahead and get started right
now with the actual slides slide 1 or
we're right here we're going to be
talking today about colorectal cancer
screening and the difference between the
guac based testing methodology and the
new fit test so we're in the modern era
now colorectal cancer what is it quite
simply it's cancers of the colon and
rectum i but that wasn't a surprise to
any of you you know exactly what that
word means and and what we deal with it
currently so why should you care about
colorectal cancer and colorectal cancer
screening well first of all there were
about a hundred and thirty seven
thousand almost cases of colon cancer in
the United States in the year of 2014
out of those nearly one hundred and
thirty-seven thousand cases we had over
50,000 deaths from colorectal cancer in
the United States that is more deaths
than the number of people that visit
Disney World on any given day we look in
terms of that that means that colorectal
cancer is the number to cancer causing
deaths in the United States it's higher
than many other cancers that we pay a
lot more attention to and we'll talk
about the differences in why we pay
attention to different cancers ahead of
time you know this is a disease because
it has such a high occurrence and such a
high death rate that we need to focus
more attention on we need to focus more
intentional and it gets
campaigns out there and a lot of groups
have the American Cancer our American
Cancer Society the american college of
gastroenterology the colon cancer
alliance but it's really it's a topic
that a lot of people don't want to focus
on they don't want to think about it
because let's face it cancers that come
from your butt are a lot less sexy of
the topic than the cancers that come up
here on the ladies we like to talk about
these all the time we like to talk about
breast cancer awareness and we do great
a great job in this country of getting
awareness surrounded in screening for
breast cancer but breast cancer doesn't
come close to killing as many people as
colorectal cancer does in the United
States so it's a very important topic
they were about to discuss today I'm
going to show you a slide right here
where there's a collage of a lot of
different people that have been affected
one way or another in their lives by
colorectal cancer or people that are
just outspoken outspoken proponents of
screening and you may recognize a lot of
people that are on this list or what
they have to do with colorectal cancer
so this is this is a disease that
reaches across all socio-economic
boundaries it reaches across all ethnic
boundaries this if disease affects
everyone let's take a look a little bit
about what we're trying to do when we're
screening for colorectal cancer a lot of
colorectal cancer can be stopped before
it ever becomes a cancer we start with
this precancerous polyps that you see in
the photograph in front of us if we
detect this precancerous polyps or even
cancer at a stage one we have greater
than a seventy-four percent chance of a
five year plus survival rate that means
we need to do a better job of screening
people getting them in to see their
physician getting their screening tests
done regardless of the methodology in
order to prevent people from developing
this disease if we wait until that
cancer has developed and grown
stage 5 we're looking at a survival rate
of five plus years of six percent or
less that's a devastating percentage
when you think about how easy it is for
us to catch this disease long before it
ever turns into cancer at a stage one so
what we're looking for when we do our
colorectal cancer screening we're hoping
to find these precancerous polyps that
are bleeding that showing increased
amount of blood in the lower GI before
we ever have to deal with the disease
such as cancer that gets to stage one
stage two three or four the ways that we
go about that screening are different
we're going to go over some of them
right now the recommended screening
tests and intervals according to the US
Preventive tasks Preventive Services
Task Force are as follows there are
three of them they recommend a high
sensitivity fecal occult blood test
which checks for hidden blood in three
consecutive stool samples this should be
done every year they also recommend a
flexible sigmoidoscopy it's where the
physician uses a flexible lighted tube
sigmoid scope to look at the interior
walls of the rectum and part of the
colon this is about the lower quarter to
lower third of the colon we do this
every five years and then we do the high
sensitivity fecal occult blood test in
between there as well the sigmoidoscope
is effective because many of these
colorectal cancers center around right
near the rectum or in that area about
fifty percent on one colonoscopy is what
is considered to be the gold standard in
the recommendations and the physicians
going to use a colonoscope flexible
lighted to to look at the interior walls
of the rectum and the entire colon this
is recommended to be doing every 10
years in the general population
beginning at age 50 up to 75 for your
average population african-americans
should be tested beginning at age
45 and if you have a family history of
cancer in your family you need to be
screened starting 10 years before your
family member first degree family member
was diagnosed with cancer when we're
talking about the colonoscopy one thing
keeping point as well as that samples of
the tissue may be collected for closer
examination or these polyps may actually
be snared and removed as part of the
colonoscopy so the colonoscopy can be
used as a screening test or as a
follow-up diagnostic tool when the
results of the other screening tests are
positive there are other methodologies
out there but the preventive services
task force recognizes that they're out
there but they have not met the
recommendation list yet although most
expert groups generally recommend the
high sensitivity fecal occult blood test
the sigmoidoscopy or the colonoscopy as
the three standard tests the other tests
that are available or stool DNA tests
virtual colonoscopies double contrast
barium enemas the only one on this list
that we're really going to go through
any kind of detail on is the stool DNA
test there is a newer test that's out
now and there are a lot of questions
surrounding this test it's new it's
getting a lot of press a lot of people
come by and ask me questions on what I
think this test is about and i will say
that i think the stool DNA test or
molecular testing in general is probably
going to be the future that's probably
where we're going in august of 2014 the
fda approved this stool DNA test at the
same time the pilot program known as the
parallel review the Centers for Medicare
& Medicaid Services CMS proposed
national coverage for the test they
agree that they were going to reimburse
the lab for doing this expensive stool
DNA test as I stated earlier today tits
it's not been incorporated into the
clinical practice guidelines or it's not
the recommended test yet by the US
preventive services task force but we're
going to monitor that test we all have
high hopes for me like molecular testing
to be the future at this point when you
do a stool DNA test and it will provide
you with results that are similar to a
fit test which is what we're going to
talk about in detail in this lecture and
at the end of the day a negative result
on the stool DNA test does not mean that
you have no cancer a positive result on
a stool DNA test does not mean that you
have cancer the sensitivity and
specificity of that test come out to be
very similar to what the fit test is so
my bottom line and another bottom line
for the US Preventive Services Task
Force at this point is to say that with
the cost factor built in you might as
well do the five dollar fit test instead
of doing the 500 plus dollars tool DNA
test at this point when the results are
similar hopefully as we move forward
over the next handful years maybe within
the next decade we're going to see
drastically increased results for the
stool DNA test so that's something to
keep a look out for in the future the
virtual colonoscopy is a sensitive CT
scan the double contrast barium enema
again another methodology but there are
a lot of polyps that we're looking for
that are not the nice round polyp that
we talked about in this photograph that
we have here very easy to detect many
polyps are very flat they're easily
missed by these other types of testing
and sometimes easily missed by something
as advanced as a colonoscopy so just
keep an eye on idea out there there are
other methodologies that are available
but the three that we discussed here are
the recommended screening tests you've
got your high sensitivity fecal occult
blood test your flexible sigmoidoscopy
or your colonoscopy let's talk about the
original stool cards this is a GF oh BTW
or guaiac based
fecal occult blood test was introduced
in 1971 to the United States the term
black is the paper surface used in the
test that actually has a resin from a
tree quiet tree actually the the paper
surface is impregnated with the test
involves dietary and medication
restrictions for several days prior to
the test some of those restrictions
include iron supplements animal meat
containing animal blood I don't know any
animal meat that doesn't contain animal
blood so if you do let me know several
different vegetables that may cause
peroxidase activity like radishes and
cauliflower horseradish you also have to
abstain from your vitamin C you should
avoid excessive drinking you should
avoid your nonsteroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs all of these
prep should take place before you do
your typical diet based fecal occult
blood test and for the quiet based fecal
occult blood test that the valid test
requires three consecutive samples on
these cards so what has happened over
the years since that test was developed
44 years ago were introduced in the
United States market over that 44 years
ago is that patients were not complying
with the prep they were not doing the
dietary and medication restrictions that
they were doing they weren't doing the
three days of testing they may do one
test decide that it wasn't a pleasant
experience go ahead and throw those
stool cards away never return them to
their doctor all kinds of different
messes they're involved in this so you
doctor prescribes three cards to the
patient fifty percent of the time those
three cards go in the garbage and are
never to be seen again it's a waste of
money on the physicians side and the
patient never gets screened so what
happened along the way the physician has
decided that they were going to take
things in
their own hands literally started
performing digital rectal exams as part
of the annual exam now digital rectal
exams are performed for a lot of
different reasons but the doctors
decided well since I already have this
sample on my fingertip after I do a
digital rectal exam I'm going to go
ahead and use a quiet based fecal occult
blood test and i'm going to kill two
birds with one stone while doing this so
if those of you that don't know what a
digital rectal exam is the physician
gloves up lubes up inserts a finger into
the rectum and they're checking for
abnormal areas lumps lesions a lot of
different things right at the anus and
rectum it is not an acceptable form of
colorectal cancer screening by itself
and the College of American Pathologists
website in this two sentence paragraph
it says even when done in office with it
with a black based fecal occult blood
test you're going to miss about
ninety-five percent of cancers so it is
completely ineffective for physicians to
be doing digital rectal exams with a
fecal occult blood test glad based card
now that we have that out of the way and
we realize that a lot of us need to
start questioning the methodologies in
which we currently are doing the cancer
screening the ACG has good news they
support the joint guideline
recommendation that older guaiac based
fecal occult blood as be abandoned as a
method for colorectal cancer screening
furthermore the ACG recommends the fit
as the preferred cancer detection test I
haven't gone over it up to this point
but we'll just say that the terms I fo b
or fit are interchangeable and those
terms stand for email chemical
immunologic immunoassay you'll hear
those terms used interchangeably fecal
occult blood test fit i fo b same thing
newer test you'll hear it called that so
if we're not talking about the glaad
based people
cold blood test we're talking about fit
or ifo be when we're talking about the
digital rectal exams before we get too
far ahead there are many fit tests that
can be utilized off-label by doing a
sample produced by a digital rectal exam
so we don't tell physicians how to be
physicians if they want to continue to
do the digital rectal exam we would
recommend that they at least use a test
like the fit test which does not require
the patient to prep ahead of time this
is key what we're trying to do in
healthcare is we're trying to reduce
costs in the system but we're trying to
screen more the general public the ways
that we do about screening more people
yet taking costs out of the system or
we're looking for ways that are actually
costing us more money when a doc is
doing a digital rectal exam with a glad
based card we end up sending a high
number of people to get a colonoscopy
because we received a positive result
yet that positive result is produced by
the fact that the patient has not
prepped by dietary or medication
restrictions before taking the test so
an example patient comes into the
emergency room of the hospital
complaining of lower GI pain fecal
occult blood test is performed with
hemoccult card by digital rectal exam
from the ER physician a positive result
comes up because the patient had steak
broccoli and cantaloupe for lunch
yesterday so they're referred upstairs
to get a colonoscopy the cost of that
colonoscopy the anesthesia the bed time
everything associated with that
colonoscopy has now been wasted and
added to the cost in the system because
we got an invalid result from that test
because of the methodology that was used
the package insert for that grad based
fecal occult blood test nowhere states
that one sample is enough and nowhere
does it state that the sample received
by doing the feet digital rectal exam is
enough sample to smear on that card so
let's switch to what we believe should
happen if the physicians in the
emergency room are going to continue to
do the digital rectal exam to get that
sample that they need that's fine at
least use a test like I said they didn't
require that the patient prep before
they came into the office with the fit
test or the IFO be there are no dietary
no medication restrictions before the
patient comes in to get that test done
some of the advantages are listed right
here we just went over the top one no
dietary or medication restrictions means
that you get a better patient return
rate not only a better patient return
rate you're going to get a better result
from the test that's actually done
because you don't have the interfering
substances that you do with the other
methodologies of fecal occult blood
testing we have an increased specificity
and higher sensitivity with the fit test
or ifo be over the black based cards
that means that you're going to get
fewer false positives for colorectal
cancer screening that is goes a great
way to reducing that cost in the
healthcare system that we're looking to
reduce the fit test or I fo b is
specific to lower GI bleeding which
makes it the ideal test for colorectal
cancer screening now I know a lot of you
out there saying that's great but we
utilize the fecal occult blood test for
things other than just colorectal cancer
screening and I understand that we have
pages and pages and pages of icd-9 codes
that are going to show us different
conditions that we may find that will
cause increased blood in the lower GI
also understand that a lot of physicians
are not just looking for blood in the
lower GI they're also looking for blood
in the upper GI the first rebuttal that
they will give as a reason for not
wanting to switch over to the fit test
if they believe that the quiet base
card kills two birds with one stone
meaning they can look at upper GI and
lower GI with one test my refute to that
rebuttal would be that you're not
killing two birds with one stone you're
merely maiming two birds with that one
stone because while it is true that that
grad based fecal occult blood card will
show bleeding in upper and lower GI it's
not the ideal test to use for either
situation the cutoff level is still too
high and our dietary restrictions for
the lower GI portion we've already gone
through those and for the upper GI
bleeding the pH level is not where it
needs to be so there are some products
out there we recommend using a gastric
cult card for upper GI bleeding the
physicians should have an idea about
exactly where they're looking or
suspicion for whether they're looking
for upper or lower GI bleeding to begin
with so why not use a very specific test
to substantiate your belief that you're
going to find something here we know
that if a patient has coffee ground
emesis or if they have black tar stool
you're probably looking for an upper GI
bleed go ahead and use a gastric gold
card because it's a very specific pH
balance test to test for that upper GI
bleed if you suspect a lower GI bleed
then please use the fit test or ifo be
because there are no dietary or
medication restrictions for that test
and the cutoff level is much lower where
it needs to be we have new cpt codes
when I say new I mean over the past 10
years fit is nothing new I fo b is
nothing new my particular product has
been CLIA waived and FDA approved in the
United States since 2004 so where our
11th year now this is not brand new
information it's been disseminated for
quite a while but we have billing codes
I hear the new billing codes are to be
utilized the same as the older building
codes are utilized you must put the QW
modifier on the end of the codes to show
that the test is CLIA waived one of the
great aspects about this fit test or
about ifo be if you look at the National
reimbursement based upon Medicare it's
21 dots 65 cents this 21 dot 65 cents
when you're working off of reimbursement
indicates substantial revenue potential
if you're at the physician office level
or if you're at the lab level reference
lab level you can see with a cost of in
the ballpark of five to six dollars per
test how making fifteen sixteen
seventeen dollars per patient could be
beneficial to your facilities so there
are new codes to be utilized for the IFO
be there used the same one as the older
codes were for the glide based fecal
occult blood tests we talked about why
people don't get screened for their
colorectal cancer needs and berkeley
came out with a paper a handful years
ago and their summary was basically that
we believe that the colonoscopy is good
is the gold standard but really the gold
standard for colorectal cancer screening
should be whatever we can get the
patient to complete whether it's a quiet
based fecal occult blood test done in
the right methodology with the right
prep in the right three cards or the fit
test or the colonoscopy we need to
provide people options if we provide
them only one option which is a
colonoscopy and they either are afraid
of the procedure because they've heard
stories from other people they're afraid
of the procedure because they have
something in their mind that may be
untrue whether their insurance won't
cover the colonoscopy which is rare or
whether they just don't have insurance
and can't afford the colonoscopy we have
to be able to provide the general public
several different options so this
wellness letter from birth
I said you know what the gold standard
is whatever we can get the patient to
actually complete and I think that's
worth noting how about you know just
plain not being aware the more advanced
form of fecal occult blood test is the
fit test and it's superior in several
ways this comes from gastroenterology
and April of 2012 so again this is not
new information it only requires one
stool sample instead of three patients
are more apt to complete the test it's
more accurate than the standard test
because it identifies antigens in the
blood and and it's not looking for him
so the guad based fecal occult blood
tests are looking for him it doesn't
differentiate between whether it's
animal blood human blood or other works
off a peroxidase activity and as long as
there's blood or peroxidase activity
present it's going to show you a
positive result the fit or the IFO b is
only going to show you a positive result
when that antigen-antibody complex shows
that there is an increased amount of
human hemoglobin present in this test
we're not looking for him at all we're
only looking for the globin portion of
human hemoglobin so it's important to
note the differences between the two
tests the fit is being used more and
more in the US and we continue to gain
but sixty to sixty-five percent of the
physicians out there in the United
States are still using the outdated
guaiac methodology of testing even
though at the end of two thousand eight
the american college of gastroenterology
said abandon that method so change is
slow I like to say the oxen are slow but
the earth is patient maybe if we all
continue to work together to spread this
information we will eventually get the
switch from the outdated product over to
the newer product you know the Brits get
it they say that there's persuasive
evidence that the new blood test fit is
more effective test for bowel screening
everybody understands that the Cancer
Research UK's director of policy
we for whatever reason in the United
States our slow to adapt Canada has
stated that a colorectal cancer
screening program similar to those in
existence for breaths and cervical
cancers would reduce death rates by up
to eighty three percent and reduce
incidents way up to eighty-one percent
according to a BC study in the canadian
medical association journal i don't know
how more plainly to put it to foes we
need to change what we're doing we need
to screen more people with the proper
screening test so that we can save more
lives is anybody paying attention to
this I just said that sixty to
sixty-five percent of the physicians in
the United States are still using the
outdated black method of testing ranges
in reasoning for this is what i did in
med school it's what I'm used to it's
what I know it's what uncomfortable
using its what's available to me any
number of reasons why they're still
using it there were over 50 million
fecal occult blood tests and we're
talking about guaiac fecal occult blood
test performed in United States in 2011
there were only just over five million I
fo b or fit test performed that same
year as you can see the huge advantage
goes to the grad based fecal occult
blood test we need to change that six
thousand plus labs reported quarterly
proficiency testing methods as the guac
or the high sensitivity guac to cap API
in Italy that's a lot of labs that are
still using an outdated methodology
imagine what we could be doing how many
lives we could be saving if we just made
the simple switch over to the antibody
test instead of the test that works off
of a black peroxidase activity you know
ignorance is no longer an excuse we
talked about this information and how
it's been out there we're coming up now
in a handful years on ten years since
the ACG updated its recommendations so
patient benefit is something that people
can't go off of that they have no idea
that it's more beneficial for the
patients look at the cost and the ROI
you know the average cost of the glaad
based card is a buck and it's
reimbursing it just under five dollars
currently the average cost for the fit
or I fo b is in the ballpark of five to
six dollars yet it's reimbursing it
sixteen dollars and fifty cents on the
national average if it's better patient
care and it's a revenue stream for your
facilities why would you not want to
switch to the methodology you know for
benchmarking as part of the Affordable
Care Act and accountable care
organizations and the future of Medicine
outcome based medicine is here you're
going to start being penalized for
readmissions you're going to be
penalized for things that happened that
you missed imagine this scenario we
talked about the patient coming into the
emergency room the emergency room
physician performs a digital rectal exam
smears that sample on the quiet based
fecal occult blood test and gets a
negative result says hey everything's
good to go here we don't need to worry
about anything that patient develops
colorectal cancer within the next couple
of years that patient dies from
colorectal cancer and the family starts
to do a little bit research and realizes
that they've done all their studies on
colorectal cancer screening
recommendations and
they go back and look and see the
physician that performed that test
performed a test which was recommended
to be abandoned by a governing body such
as the ACG now they're going to sue the
hospital and then physician how much is
that going to cost you in the overall
scheme of things in the healthcare field
so the days of just performing things
because it's what we're used to
performing or because we can't afford to
make the switch that we're showing you
proof right now of how you can afford
not to switch over to ifo be again we
all need to work together to achieve
this goal to make sure that we
understand what the recommendations are
why the newer test is more beneficial
than the old test and what we're going
to do about it let's take a look at
another study that was done this study
compares different fit tests so we
talked about how we want to get
everybody to switch over to the fit or
ifo be from the go-ahead based testing
method we know that we should do that so
you should be able to just contact your
distributors such as Cardinal and say
hey give me the fit test and they'll
just pick one for you right or you can
base it upon cost or whatever your
methodology is throw a dart at a board
who knows but not every fit is created
equally they all work on the same
mechanism which is an antibody test but
each test is completely different they
all have different cut-offs levels and
this is hugely important when you're
trying to weigh that balance between
patient care and cost effectiveness they
all have different collection methods
there are different packaging options
that are available with different
manufacturers for your fit test there's
different processes to actually run the
test in your lab each test uses
different antibodies I won't mention the
company but there was a company that was
the market leader in fit
handful years ago and they were forced
to withdraw that test from the
marketplace and due to some abnormal
results which were coming from the
antibodies that they were using this
company was outsourcing their Hannah
bodies to a company in China that was
providing them and the results were not
consistently cutting off at the level
that they selected so the results were
doing this sometimes higher sometimes
lower and we know statistically that we
should be seeing a positive result
somewhere in the ballpark of nine to
fourteen percent of the time on a fit
test if you're seeing results outside of
that you need to question a few
different things one of them is how the
patient's doing the test the other could
be how you're processing the test and
the third could be the actual test
itself so we talked about these cutoff
levels each manufacturer sets their own
cutoff level the chart that I've given
you in front here was taken from a study
from the clearview test that was done a
handful of years ago and this test went
through different cut off levels to show
what results are going to get so at the
15 anagram cutoff level there were 17
true positive results we didn't miss any
at all which is great 75 nanograms
however once we take that one step up
we're missing a cancer already at 75
nanograms as you go up the list we're
missing more and more cancers already on
these lists again I'm not going to
associate names with these different
companies but i will say that there are
many companies out there that set their
cutoff level at 25 nanograms because
they don't want to miss any cancers 25
in my opinion maybe a little bit low
because again we're trying to reduce the
number of useless colonoscopies that we
perform in our facilities with a 25
milligram cutoff level
you're going to find a lot of people
that that's just their average amount of
blood in their lower GI on any given day
the upper levels there are some
companies out there that set their
cutoff level and 100 there are some
companies out there that said their
cutoff level at 300 because they
understand the aspect of wanting to
limit the number of colonoscopies that
are performed in saving money that way
however they're not really taken into
account the number of cancers that
you're missing by increasing those
cuddles levels so this is a very
informative slide for everyone we'll
talk a little bit about something that's
not on this slide and again it talks
about recommendations for fecal occult
blood testing or the the fit or the IFO
be all right before we get into the
summary I'm actually going to go back a
slide we talked about different
methodologies and different cut off
levels we went into detail about the
cutoff levels the collection methods
just about everybody in the IFO be or
fit world agrees that two tests are
better than one statistically you're
going to get about seventeen percent
better results by doing two consecutive
bowel movements that you will by doing
three which is what the traditional
cards called for there is ZERO
statistical difference with a fit
between two tests and three tests so if
your Doc's are ordering three
consecutive bowel movements on the fit
test they're just wasting that extra
tests they're wasting money on it there
is ZERO statistical reason to do so we
do have studies that support that now we
find that because we all agree that two
tests are better than one and before I
go further let's talk about the semantic
difference between required and
recommended
again I say two tests are recommended
and that's agreed upon by everyone but
only one test is required and you're
only being reimbursed for one test so
these are key factors to keep in mind as
well especially when we talk about
packaging options so there are some
manufacturers out there that say okay if
two tests are recommended we're going to
go ahead and we're going to combine two
tests into one so that not only are we
not increasing the cost but we can take
care of those two stool samples well as
we're looking at this cut off level
charter we think about what's normal in
a human being and what is clinically
significant let's just say that myself
to other people let's say I have a
normal amount in my lower GI of 13
anagrams of blood per milliliter on any
given day let's say that the two other
people next to me they are 10 and 5
respectively so if we all do a two-day
test and we combine it or collect two
days of sample and we combine it into
one test what's going to happen to the
other two folks next to me is nothing
significant they're both going to show
up as negative because if we double the
five will get 10 and if we double the 10
we get 20 we're still under that 25
nanogram cut off which a lot of
manufacturers use however on my test
because I'm normally at 30 if you double
my test and then run that in one it's
going to show that I have a
concentration of 60 nanograms per
milliliter of blood in my lower GI and
that's going to show as significant
you're going to refer me for a
colonoscopy this colonoscopy and the
costs associated with it not to mention
the percentage of perforations that
occur with these colonoscopies and the
cost that's associated with them is a
waste of money because clinically I
should be negative
that's the danger when you combine two
samples into one test I believe there is
actually a manufacturer out there right
now that is saying it's okay in their
package insert to combine three days of
a stool sample to be run in one fit test
so again you run the risk of spending
more money doing needless colonoscopies
when you're going to make the decision
to switch over to fit really study
what's available to you study what your
options are find out what your
pathologists and what your medical
directors think should be the correct
cutoff level find a company that's going
to provide the packaging options
combined with the cutoff level and the
methodologies they're going to be right
for your facilities based upon the
results that you're looking for so in
summary on their colorectal cancer is
the second leading killer in cancers we
talked about this breast cancer is a
sexy topic to talk about it's something
that everybody wants to get behind to
promote but we need to do a better job
of promoting screening for colorectal
cancer as well the ACG in the article
released at the end of 2008 published
recommends abandoning the older glad
based fecal occult blood tests as a
method for colorectal cancer screening
according to the College of American
Pathologists digital rectal exam is not
an acceptable form of colorectal cancer
screening even when used with a
graph-based fecal occult blood test
you're going to be missing ninety-five
percent of what you're looking for now
we know we talked about why physicians
have taken matters into their own hands
because they couldn't trust their
patients to do the proper prep and
return the wide-based fecal occult blood
cards that they had in the past but I
promise you fit has a higher patient
compliance rate based upon a couple
different things the collection
methodology a lot of manufacturers had
made that collection a lot easier for
the patient
the patient doesn't have to prep ahead
of time they can go home and do it
immediately that night or that evening
or the next day they don't have to wait
to do their test and they only have to
do one instead of doing three so the fit
with no instruction whatsoever just
handing the kit to the patient saying go
home and do this follow the instructions
will come back to you around fifty
percent of the time with proper patient
instruction and taking that extra minute
and a half that it takes to show your
patient what to expect before they go
home to complete that test we have over
an eighty percent return rate with the
fit test so physicians you may dau us to
begin with but we will tell you you will
see higher patient compliance rate and
what is the federal goal we didn't
mention it up to this point but the
federal goal is to have eighty percent
of the viable population tested for
colorectal cancer screening by the year
twenty eighteen that is a lofty goal we
will not reach that goal unless we all
work together and do our part to get the
people that are in that age range 50 to
75 to get screened unless we show them
the different methodologies that are
available to them unless we encourage
them and continue to encourage them to
take it into these tests why eighty
percent by 2018 is a huge goal but we
can do it if we work together another
point to remember with fit or I fov may
generate significant revenue for your
practice if you're a physician office or
if you're a lab and you work off of
reimbursement there is no reason not to
avail yourself of the revenue potential
and the better medicine that's available
to you with the fit test and according
to the Berkeley paper what did we say
the gold standard is whichever test you
can actually get the patient to complete
and return because unless you complete
and return your test in the proper
method
you haven't been screened your heater
requirements haven't been met nothing
has been done so when we talk about
colorectal cancer screening obviously I
have a passion for it it's very
important we can save lives we can
reduce the incidence of colorectal
cancer we can reduce the death rate for
people that actually develop colorectal
cancer we all need to do our part of
getting that sixty to sixty-five percent
to switch over to the newer methodology
and we need to continue to research and
development research and develop these
newer methodologies such as the
molecular testing where the results are
going to get even better and more
worthwhile as an indicator as to who
needs to get a colonoscopy and who
doesn't need to get a colonoscopy ahead
of time so while you sit there thinking
about that and we ponder what's
happening in a world of colorectal
cancer awareness colorectal cancer
screening again I'm going to bring this
slide back up think about the people
that are listed here on this collage how
they were affected by colon cancer
colorectal cancer think about the people
that you know friends family members
that have been affected by this D
disease think about how many of them
could have been prevented ahead of time
by a simple five dollar poop test thank
you for your time everybody open to
questions now please give me your
concerns and let me try to answer your
questions for you have certain questions
well thank you rob for that informative
presentation I'm thrilled to be part of
the cardinal health lab exchange before
we start the Q&A session I'd like to
remind our audience that you can submit
your questions in the Q&A box that can
be found by clicking on the green
hearing a button on the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can so
with that we'll see if we have any
questions at this point I mean while
I would like to thank our sponsor here
ashore for making today's educational
webcast possible and after the
presentation after we conclude please
make sure to head to the community of
learning following to have the
opportunity to engage in a live chat
with Rob couple Lucy and and your peers
as well as have any questions answered
that you may have and learn Nora you
know in dr. Rob about colon cancer
diagnostic tool fecal occult blood
testing in modern era if we don't have
any questions at this point I'd like to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through October of this year you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
an ounce for to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event again
hedrick community of learning to talk to
rob i hope to see you all again next
time and until then thank you and
goodbye